ja und diese meldung hier ist ganz
frisch reingekommen georg ziel ist kein
mörder oder dieb der 54 jährige saß
sechs monate in münster im knast weil er
keine rundfunk beträge zahlt thiele ist
edv zeichner seit 25 jahren ohne
fernseher seit 10 auch ohne radio und
2013 hat er zuletzt gz gezahlt derzeit
sind das monatlich 17 50 und
mittlerweile schuldet er dem wdr knapp
1900 euro und seine zelle dieser so aus
acht quadratmeter groß bett schrank
tisch wc und auch hier kein fernseher
und während seiner erzwingungshaft trat
hier zweimal in den hungerstreik und
jetzt ist er raus raus aus dem knast der
jva die sechs monate hat er überstanden
aber der sender besteht weiterhin auf
die zahlung wie es jetzt weitergeht ist
noch unklar
michael engelberg ist vor ort und hat
die ersten schritte in freiheit verfolgt
wie waren die
ja guten morgen herr aus münster also
man muss schon eine sehr skurrile sache
um 9 uhr wieder nach neuen ist georg
thiel aus der vorteil der jva münster
gekommen eine große unterstützergruppe
jubel es haben ihm leute mercy
schokoladen überreicht und blumen ein
großer applaus und die aktie hatte ein
schild um den hals mit der aufschrift
danke werde er hat jetzt tatsächlich 180
tage in erzwingungshaft gesetzen und hat
mir gesagt dass er die zeit eigentlich
sehr genossen habe und er habe gezielt
er habe auch viel darüber nachgedacht
was da überhaupt passiert sei er wäre
auch bereit fünf euro zu zahlen aber
mehr auch nicht um nur leute zu
unterstützen die fernseh gucken und
radiohören die überhaupt gar kein geld
haben aber nichtsdestotrotz kann er
überhaupt nicht verstehen warum er in
haft gesessen habe aber er würde es auch
weiterhin so machen nicht bezahlen und
er würde auch weitere haftstrafen und
erzwingungshaft in kauf nehmen ganz
herzlichen dank für diese aktuellen
schilderung ein mann in freiheit
herzlichen dank
[Musik]